today's video is sponsored by surf shark
today's topic
yoshi from the bachelor wretch is back i
expected way more from the oldest
bachelorette in history bro what are you
talking about
remember you're almost 14. remember
you're almost
40. went full petty
he went all over yeah you went
um you're almost 40
hag
hag obviously whatever chemistry and
good feelings you had
it all changed dramatically after the
strip
dodge ball date a date you you weren't
even on
what was it that struck such a chord
with you for context uh we did a
previous video on this but basically um
bachelorette asked a bunch of dudes to
get down pretty much most but naked
and to do dodgeball and he got upset
about it plus a few other things that
she did that made him feel like she
wasn't interested
in actually dating and that she was
wasting everyone's time
which he got mad about because she's
like i'm spending time away from my
daughter and blah blah
so he blew up on her during the show and
he got a little bit of petty
let's be honest you know i mean there
were some red flags that popped up on
our first group date actually and then
the strip dodge ball was definitely
something that i did not agree with
but it was more than that it was the
actual fact of the humiliation
for the losing team i'm a very outspoken
person i'm going to speak my mind and
you know i think everyone deserves that
uh that honesty and you know
i was raw but i don't regret sticking up
for these guys
i would do picking up for us yeah okay i
was on a date
yeah i was too and so was damar yeah he
actually were three of the
most naked guys i think i don't have did
you have a problem
at the end of the day joseph like we
could have said no right but
i just don't get because you weren't
there like so it does it doesn't matter
if i was there or not i can have my own
opinion about it
whether he's there or not is irrelevant
it's more so about the intention of the
bachelorette as she goes on dates with
people
you know if i'm going on a date with
somebody but then she's going on
different dates where she's basically
you know jumping in in orgies and doing
stuff like that it might reflect
terribly even if i'm not their present
what you do on your time and how you
date has a reflection on how we're going
to date
it's like if you got one job how you
behave on other jobs is also going to
reflect on that job if that's why they
look at your resume
isn't that correct they look at your
pack worse as well as past work
right so so of course respect of whether
he's there or not
her behavior basically gives him an
indication of where she's at with dating
the thing that happened in white trigger
as a guy
is that he says that he was defending
the guys
that's what he said he said you just
said that and that's why the guys are
like
yeah but you weren't there why are you
defending us has nothing to do with us
which i understand that point but i
understand exactly what you're saying
like
it doesn't change what you're saying it
doesn't change at all but i see why the
guys are like bro you're trying to speak
for us but you weren't there and i
didn't bring it up with
you know really like any of y'all no but
but once you start saying it it makes
us three look like because we're the
ones that did it willingly
yeah you guys are goofballs let me get
this straight you're mad at him because
it makes you look terrible because you
went through with it yeah
you look terrible because you went
through with it and she put you through
that but you also consented so that's on
you
that's on you you look stupid before he
said anything that's your problem
it's not what he said that makes him
lose look stupid it's what you did
yeah but because he respected what he
was said or not me looking at a bunch of
grown ass man stripping down by naked to
appease
one single girl you guys super pathetic
you can listen you can argue that with
anyone you want don't argue with me i
already have my opinion on it
all right and i brought it up to the
source
way no not in the book yeah it was it
was kind of listen
i'm sorry you can't express like how you
feel like as a man to someone but
like that's how it is that's betty
because that had nothing to do with it
but
petty but also at the same time these
guys seem super simply
here's my thing okay it's come out
afterwards that this girl
had zero intentions of dating anybody on
the show and had already made up her
mind beforehand
imagine being isolated for multiple
weeks going through test being away from
your family to try to be with somebody
who's already wasted everybody's time so
she
was unbelievably disrespectful and it
turned out that joseph was right about
how she feels about dating yeah but the
thing is
that's what the bachelorette and the
bachelor is
but i'm talking about the point where
you're saying that this is super simpy
what is super simply
is bachelor oh yeah we agree on that
that that's
all i said we agree on that's the minute
you're on the bachelorette or the
bachelor i agree you
you fall into that category because
that's the name of the game yeah
yeah but it's crazy that these guys are
going to sim this heart
he called her out on her bus and these
guys if they don't simp this hard
it discredits their simping you know
what i mean they already said yes to the
symphony when they they signed up on
this
okay and then being like yeah no i'm not
about that
it just discredits them simply from the
get-go
hold on a second i think we all back and
see that he looks like a kid who got his
lunch money taken
shut up
you know when your mom beats you and you
get through a spectrum
[ __ ] you can't yell because your mom's
on the other side is gonna beat your ass
even
you can't say [ __ ] today's video is
sponsored by surf shark vpn
so vpn is basically an application or
web extension that you could use on your
web browser or on your internet
to mask your ip address basically hiding
your location
from whatever website you're interacting
with now you might think
why would i want to hide where i'm at it
doesn't matter well unfortunately there
are places that block you
based off of your ip address and so if
you're trying to view
online content on let's download certain
things based off where you live
those things could be restricted now i
like watching tv shows
feel me sometimes they're foreign feel
me and
when that happens basically i use a vpn
to be able to bypass that so i can watch
what i want to watch because i feel like
the internet's at its best
when everything's accessible if you use
promo code abba and preach
you get 83 off plus three months free
so take advantage of the deal watch what
you want to watch and don't be
restricted by anyone's barriers
you deserve to go wherever you'd like to
go i think we all back and see that
that conversation started out very calm
cool and collected it didn't like
accelerate until claire started talking
about control the whole conversation
and when she tried to express and say
joseph i completely understand where
you're coming from no
shut up yourself then you just took it
to a whole new
level of disrespect you guys know that
you guys are not chosen by her
you understand that there's nothing to
fight for anymore god
damn you guys understand that right like
y'all
lost equally you understand that right
there's nothing to fight for
guys like this are the reason why so
many women have disillusioned ideas of
like how men should behave
because these guys will go above and
beyond to simp for a woman who spat in
their face and it's just crazy and he's
like bruh
let her husband defend her why are you
going out of the woodwork after she spat
in your face
like how pathetic and grovelly do you
have to be to be like
i'm the defender of justice she got a
man
she chose him before the show started
shut your goddamn mouth
emancipate yourself fermented simpin
nothing but yourself can free your mind
tell me when i was walking out why you
gotta wait a few months to tell me i'm
telling you
i am 10 feet from you and i am telling
you right now not just riley
we're all telling you how it is right
now yeah man i think
the most shocking thing is that you have
no regret or remorse
not only are you owning the behavior but
the way in which you went about it
is really shocking i respect y'all's
opinion but i have my own opinion and
i'm gonna stand by that
so just so you know what they're giving
me vibes of
they're giving me like uh oprah vibes
during the meghan markle interview
what we're clear when you watch that
you're like
that's cool i would never mind anyone
talking to my daughter like that
i hate when people use that argument the
fact that it's in your family that's
your daughter your mom
doesn't have absolution of
accountability
it's not what it means you know i mean
it could be my
like you have to acknowledge that even
if it's your daughter
your son your father your grandfather
your cause
they can still be shitty people and you
gotta hold them
accountable well no that everything will
change if it would be my daughter
then no i could possibly have someone
talk to my
daughter what if your daughter was a
shitty ass person
do some shitty [ __ ] and you know what
[ __ ] it we've all done some shitty [ __ ]
oh
all of us the fact that
i'm someone's son or whatever
doesn't no you say sorry you said no she
said
you hold yourself accountable for what
you did the fact that you related to the
person doesn't change anything
doesn't remove the accountability oh
yeah it's my daughter yeah
no one would talk like that if the
person is shitty the person is shitty
or done some shitty things i rarely do
this
i want to try to help you help yourself
i've seen a lot of crazy stuff in 20
years but
that was really not a good look it just
the way the way it escalated the way you
spoke
but what i would love is if you could
just
see that and just be like you know what
i do see that and claire
for that i'm sorry i'm not going to
apologize to claire with all due respect
like i don't
thank god bro thank god imagine trying
to core someone into an apology that
they don't want to give thanks this show
is utter
tragedy i really don't care what any of
these guys really think about me i'm
going to stay true to myself
okay i imagine being this like dejected
because somebody's not a symp like you
because the rest of these guys are super
simple i'm sorry
but like the way that they're reacting
to everything that he says and his
difference of opinion
the fact that they don't like the way
that he specifically talked to a woman
who is also disrespectful towards him
who cares it's like she was the point of
the fact that she was wasting your
time guys but more than that it's like
also like she reciprocating that
conversation it just it's so fascinating
to me that
i can't believe that he said all that
when i'm like bro did you not hear what
she said
does she not say the exact same stuff
about oh i don't want you erasing any of
my kids do you not remember her saying
that either no
okay i just want to make sure that's why
you weren't on the date you don't
remember another of that okay just want
to make sure
and that's the thing i just want to make
sure this is what this is what i'm
talking about when women often do these
kinds of things
their participation in whatever argument
or fight ensued
is completely ignored and the man's
reaction or action they like
it's off to the focal point you're
telling me yeah
you're telling me go ahead out of all
people you're telling me
the the guy that was security that was
bouncer i've seen
women grope men and when the guy was
like yo what the hell are you doing
they took out the guy some people
some of my bosses asked me to take out
guys that didn't do nothing
that god accepted you're telling me
like i don't know in the bar
that's what it is if a guy grabs a
girl's ass
we're thinking now the guys we're taking
it out and we should
and we should as we should i'm not even
disputing that
but if a woman does the same thing we're
not going to take the guy out
but if he and if there's something and
that's the problem if i see no one
acting no one's saying [ __ ] no one
batting an eye girls accepting me
or other people of my like other people
of my team or
other pitchers other people in the bar
nobody bats at night nobody says
nothing but the minute someone says hey
you know what hold up
wait a minute uh stop because everything
is a joke especially when they tipsy
tips no no no i'm not i'm not kidding
stop doing that and they keep on
laughing and i gotta raise my voice
because i'm not being hurt but the
minute i heard
my voice i'm the one that's being taken
out i'm the one that have to take out
people
some of my boss has been like no you
have to take this guy out now she's the
one that [ __ ]
yeah but you know girls bring boys and
boys span
so get rid of the guy you're telling me
this
man the number of time that this happens
that you get us up man
i need to chill i need to [ __ ] chill
i need to calm the [ __ ] down
shut it off
[Music]
foreign